hey guys mark and Daisy here and you're
gonna want to listen to this to
celebrate the 40th anniversary of Star
Wars we're offering fans the chance to
win not one but three once-in-a-lifetime
Star Wars experiences for 40 years
you've been the best fans in the world
bringing the franchise to life in ways
we never could have imagined and now
it's our chance to celebrate you it's
the next Star Wars force for change
fundraising initiative and it's all to
support two great causes so we've teamed
back up with omae's to give you a chance
to win a new Star Wars experience every
week of the campaign including an
overnight stay at Skywalker Ranch a
chance to appear in the upcoming Han
Solo movie and my personal favorite a
trip to LA to join me and the cast at
the world from the out of Star Wars the
last Jedi enter any week and you're in
the running to win the grand prize all
three of these incredible
once-in-a-lifetime experiences so let's
start with this week's prize a trip to
Skywalker Ranch Skywalker it's been a
while since I've been there but
fortunately we've got Daisy to tell us
all about it I'm sorry
well I figured you've been one of the
stars in the new trilogy you've been
there many times right yeah of course
Skywalker Ranch practically my home away
from home where do I begin
oh the end the end start with the end
the end
hmm yeah and really spare no detail hmm
nice size beds but not too firm you know
oh and the sheets
thread count is it's up there it's high
well I meant how each room is uniquely
designed to honor some of the great
artists inspired George's work oh that
yeah that's true
very unique well anything else you'd
like to add I mean anything at all
you've never been to Skywalker Ranch
right no I mean I go there all the time
it's like my favorite place mmm okay
well also you're gonna get to watch Star
Wars a new hope in a private screening
room and after that there's the archives
there a secret collection to some of
those prized artifacts from the Star
Wars saga it's completely off-limits to
most guests but not to you and Daisy
since you've been there so often what's
your favorite thing in there Daisy well
I won't say a word because you'll
definitely want to see this one for
yourself but to everyone watching don't
you kind of wish Daisy would tell us
just one thing that's down there and
don't you kind of wish MOG would just
let you wait and see
you've never been to Skywalker Ranch
happy Daisy
for your chance to visit Skywalker ant
and be entered for the chance to win all
three grand prize experiences click the
link or go to omae's comm forward slash
Star Wars and since every winner gets to
bring a friend
you could even invite Daisy something
tells me it would be like she's seeing
it all for the very first time maybe
they should maybe I really am asking
happy Star Wars week everybody so I'm
gonna explain what's going on with this
and all the new stuff they've announced
there's a new anthology series that's
going to be coming if you're new to the
channel I do Star Wars every week
obviously its Star Wars Celebration this
week so they'll be extra Star Wars
happening be sure to subscribe to get
everything I've got my own giveaways
that'll be going on that I'll explain at
the end of the video but as you can see
this is a much larger version of the
thing that they did for Star Wars The
Force awakens JJ Abrams had that big
video where he's like you could win a
chance to be in the movie so for the
next three weeks there's three different
prizes you can win but because they've
already shot the last Jedi it's not a
contest to actually be in that movie
it's already done it's a contest to go
to the premiere which is gonna be like
way later this year at the end of
November early December it's usually a
couple weeks before the movie actually
comes out you can win a chance to be in
the Han Solo movie which they're in the
middle of working on right now and you
can win a chance to go to the Skywalker
Ranch like obviously the comedy of this
is that Daisy Ridley herself has never
been to Skywalker Ranch if you're
wondering why that is I think they're
being honest it's mostly because that's
up near San Francisco in most of the
production that they did for Star Wars
The Force awakens happens down in Los
Angeles and over in the UK in Pinewood
Studios and Daisy Ridley herself is
British so most of her free time when
she's not working on movies is spent
over there but if she were American like
Mark Hamill she lived in Los Angeles she
would probably just go up and visit
Skywalker Ranch like all the Star Wars
people do all the time anyway I totally
love their chemistry she's adorable JJ
Abrams was going on and on about how
Mark Hamill deserves an Oscar for his
performance in the last Jedi so
hopefully some of that comes across and
whatever teasers they dropped this
weekend so if you think it's weird that
she's never been there it's just that
she doesn't live near it and most of the
production that she worked on didn't
happen anywhere near there either like
they said that the grand prize is
winning all three and it's open until
May 11th so presumably you have a chance
to win the grand prize which is all
three up to that May 11th date it's not
like they're gonna announce a winner
next week for the first prize than the
second prize but they'll probably wait
till after this is all done but if
you've ever had a chance to go to the
Skywalker Ranch most people have never
been it's amazing they have crazy
security there too
people used to try and crash it all the
time and it's all
gotten crazier now that things have
ramped back up with the new trilogy but
they still do a lot of audio work there
and obviously it's George Lucas's
primary residence so it serves a lot of
purposes but most of the ILM people like
the other people that spend most of
their time working behind the scenes on
Star Wars Lucasfilm stuff live up in the
San Francisco area the exception to that
are like all the JJ Abrams the bad robot
people that helped produce the movies
which are down here where most of the
actors live but hopefully you guys know
about Star Wars Celebration that's
mostly ramping up like late Wednesday
night early Thursday stuff will start
rolling out the 40th anniversary panel
is gonna be on Thursday Friday is gonna
be the big last Jedi panel I'll be
posting all that stuff so you guys can
leave a request for specific bonus
videos in the comments below but there
will be new footage we know about a
bunch of new characters I was thinking
about doing a last jedi new characters
video but since the trailers only a
couple days away I figured it'd just be
better to wait for the actual footage to
drop because some of them like Laura
Dern's character we've learned a little
bit about she might not be in the
trailer but there's a lot of interesting
things that have come out about snoke's
character so we can freak out about that
as soon as we get some new footage and
the other big thing too is obviously
Star Wars rebels season four they'll be
dropping a trailer for that and they
have a new anthology of books because
they got rid of the expanded universe
they sort of pushed it to the side and
called it legacy they're actually
developing a new anthology to flesh out
the really obscure Star Wars characters
that will be kind of like the new
version of the expanded universe so if
you remember the collected editions like
tales from Jabba's palace it was a book
made up of short stories for all the
weird obscure characters in Jabba's
Court they'll be doing a lot of books
like that for all the new weird
characters in the Star Wars universe of
which there are thousands so it should
be pretty cool so there's a whole bunch
of Star Wars book stuff happening this
weekend in addition to all the big movie
stuff it's just most of the focus is
going to be on last Jedi stuff so I'll
try to do as many videos as possible but
there is a new round of the rogue one
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video congratulations to last
week's giveaway winner Cameron meats
please private message me so I can get
your contact details so while you wait
for that next video you can click here
to learn all about Darth Vader's Castle
and you can click here for all the thor
ragnarok footage thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
in the next video
[Music]